hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my little humble movie review show
now it's only a couple of days until
christmas or at least that's when i'm uh
putting this up and i already kind of
[ __ ] up because remember how i said if
you've been watching my other videos uh
for this for the month of december i've
been trying to do if not necessarily
christmas themed movies uh at least ones
that were set in the wintertime and i
kind of figured out which ones i wanted
to do you know kind of ahead of time so
i could kind of get them all cranked out
and one of the ones that i put on the
list uh ended up being
not really a christmas movie and not
even really a winter movie so
you know i probably should have switched
some around the schedule like when i
found that out but oh well because i
kind of feel like the one that i did
last week which was day of the beast
probably would have better been a better
one to do like at this time because it's
close to christmas but whatever [ __ ] it
it doesn't really matter uh christmas is
just only you know i'm uploading this on
the 23rd or the 22nd if you're a patron
of december
but other than that it doesn't really
matter because people will be watching
it uh whatever time of year now the
reason that i made that mistake
was because the
first movie
because this is a sequel but the first
movie called puka
was actually a christmas movie and we
did i think we did a matinee on it last
christmas to uh christmas of 2020 so i
don't know why i just assumed that the
sequel puka lives uh they both have
exclamation points that's why i'm making
that gesture um but i just assumed that
that would be kind of along the same
lines it would be a christmas movie or a
winter movie or something like that and
it's not
but
i guess i'm gonna have to allow it
because one i watched it and i enjoyed
it quite a bit and two the first movie
is absolutely a christmas movie and this
has like the character kind of carrying
over so as i mentioned uh earlier
probably on the puka review and on my
review of pilgrim which came out around
thanksgiving
this is one of hulu's into the dark
series and if you haven't seen those
other videos or you don't know what that
is
hulu has teamed with blumhouse and they
put out a it's it's a series but they're
not like interrelated they put out a
horror movie a low budget horror movie
every month
and it usually has something whether
explicitly or tangentially to do with
the holiday that occurred during that
month
so you know they've done thanksgiving
ones they've done easter ones did they
do an easter one they've done new year's
ones the you know they've done all to
like valentine's day and i believe in
2018 or 2019
uh was their christmas entry was puka
now i really really liked uh the first
puka movie it's was really creepy it was
really well done and it does seem like
that one
is a favorite among all of the movies in
the into the dark series i haven't seen
them all i've actually only seen a
minority of them i will get around to
watching all of them one of these days
but you know i have a big long list as
you guys know and i've heard that some
of them were you know it's kind of hit
and miss because you know they're not
super high budget obviously um you know
because they're made for hulu by
blumhouse blumhouse's kind of whole
business model is to sort of crank out
these you know lower budget horror films
and it's not saying that they're bad
because a lot of them are actually
really good but there's a real quick
turnaround time on them so you know
sometimes you're not going to get these
big epic spectacle horror movies it's
just going to be kind of like an indie
movie which is what this one is as well
so the first puka introduced the
character of puka who was kind of like a
stuffed toy kind of like a creepy cute
teddy bearish type of situation and he
was kind of like a teddy ruxpin if you
guys remember the 80s like what that was
where it has like a nice setting and a
naughty setting and if you're nice it
has like it flashes these blue eyes like
these big they look kind of like
headlights and uh but when it gets angry
it kind of repeats back what you say but
like in a devilish kind of voice and its
eyes turn red now this character
kind of took off and i can see why
because it's you know actually like
pretty cool looking character design
and uh it kind of took off to the point
where i believe i don't know if it still
does but uh naughty pooka had its own uh
twitter feed and i guess like the
character of puka sort of became an
unofficial mascot of the whole into the
dark series so as i said the first puka
was very well received now the first
puka movie
if you remember we talked about it like
last year i think
and that was much more a psychological
horror film in the sense that it
concerned a dude who was hired at
christmas time to
wear the this puka suit because puka was
kind of like this new toy that had come
out and it swept the world and it was
super super famous so he took a job
being in the suit and it slowly sort of
drove him crazy and or maybe puka kind
of came to life like his demonic thing
so much more of a creepy psychological
type of thing
now this movie puka lives
it kind of went in a different direction
than that and i'm kind of glad it did
because honestly
it seems to take place in the same
universe but it's not really the same
kind of movie at all in fact it's kind
of more it has horror elements and it
has some creepy scenes in it but it's
kind of more of like a satire
or like a black comedy type of thing and
i think that was a good direction to go
in
the only thing linking the two is the
character of puka and puka being this
toy that is like massively massively
successful to a point where it's got you
know tv shows and merch and all this
other kind of stuff so this does play
with that and as i said this one
interestingly for an into the dark you
know movie in the series is it doesn't
seem to be based around a particular
holiday i saw a couple of reviewers that
said maybe easter
but even that's like pretty tenuous um i
think pretty much the only reason they
got away with it was because one this is
the only sequel so far in the intro into
the dark series which should tell you
something that the first the first puka
was so popular that they felt you know
that they could do a follow-up of it and
the fact that they kind of like invented
a holiday for this to go around which
would be like i think it's international
puka day and i was just kind of like
okay that's fine i'll roll with it so
this isn't really christmas themed or
or holiday themed in any way whatsoever
but i still had a really good time with
it so you know we're going to talk about
it so this one
kind of centers around this guy named
derek oh i should mention that this was
actually directed by alejandro uh
brugais bruguis brugues i hopefully i'm
pronouncing that sort of right sorry if
i'm not
uh he actually directed juan of the dead
which is great if you haven't seen it
and one of the segments i think it was
like the slasher movie segment in
nightmare cinema which was also like a
really a really decent anthology film if
you want to check that one out so he's
the one that directed this so the story
behind this there's a guy named derek
who's played by malcolm barrett
and he uh wrote a book about online
personalities and presumably wasn't too
flattering about some of them
so he's been living in new york city
comes from a small town but he'd been
living in new york city and he wrote
this book
and he pissed off uh this one really
really obnoxious anal wart of a youtuber
i don't remember if they call him a
youtuber in the movie maybe they just
say of influencer or whatever maybe they
can't say youtube and i'm not really
sure what the copyright is on that but
yeah so this dude's name is jax um he's
pretty much
you know like all of those [ __ ]
super popular like youtubers it's like
aimed toward like really younger people
or whatever and uh i sound like a
grandma but you know what i mean it's
just really obnoxious like everything's
yelling and all this like crazy kind of
[ __ ] going on so he's that kind of guy
so he didn't like what derek said about
him in this book so he decides that he's
going to amass his legion of followers
his jack's army if you will to
essentially ruin the dude's life and uh
they are pretty successful at doing this
in the sense that they get his publisher
to not promote his [ __ ] anymore like his
book sales tank you know every time that
he's online he's just completely
inundated with shitty messages telling
him to kill himself and stuff like that
anybody that's on that been on the
internet for any length of time uh will
know what or will be able to imagine
what being a target of this attack uh
would be like so he's pretty much
disgraced he can't uh really get another
book off the ground because his career
is you know in the toilet at this point
so he decides that he's gonna go back to
his hometown which is a small town named
spring valley uh to see kind of lick his
wounds and see if he can get his [ __ ]
back together just kind of get over this
you know so so essentially like all of
these youtubers
these irritating youtubers fans like
drove him out of new york city uh so
yeah so he goes back to the small town
uh and he gets a job
as a copywriter uh at the company that
makes puka that's like responsible for
puka
now he's uh staying with two friends of
his like childhood friends of his
whose names are molly and matt now fans
of the new mystery science theater that
came out on netflix and is going to be
doing their own thing on their gizmoplex
uh next year
uh matt and molly the married couple are
actually played by uh jonah ray and
felicia day so i thought that was kind
of neat like to see the two of them uh
in the movie together i'm not sure i
know that they've done other stuff you
know i haven't seen it like i've seen
felicia day and a couple other things
but that's mainly where i know them from
is from the new mystery science theater
so i thought that was kind of cool
seeing them
so they've kind of stayed in this small
town matt is sort of like this affable
dad type but very very skeptical whereas
molly is this very like new agey she's
got crystals all over the house and [ __ ]
like that
and they also have a daughter now there
are also two other childhood friends one
of whom is named susan and susan and
derek used to date back in the day but i
guess they broke up because he wanted he
had big city dreams and she wanted to
stay she liked it where she was so there
was that whole thing and uh she also
works at the puka company because it's
this big it's called i think it's called
spectacular contraptions incorporated or
something and i guess i i was led to the
implication being that this is kind of a
small town and this is kind of like the
big main company where a lot of people
in the town work so susan works there as
well and then they also have a friend
named ben or benny uh who became a
policeman so he's like the sheriff
and he's like a really cool guy but kind
of wish he had more scenes because he's
like super funny but uh but yeah so
that's kind of like the the gang now uh
as it happens members of jax's army one
of whom is also this irritatingly young
and equally obnoxious dude who's like
the social media guy at the puka company
uh he basically tells all of jax's
legions of friends like he basically
doxes him and he's like he's back here
in spring valley this is where he's
living uh this is where he works uh so
you know come [ __ ] him up
so he starts getting harassed at his
friend matt molly's house which makes
him feel really guilty because he's like
no you know now their house is getting
egged and he's having other things
happen to him too like you know he's
getting yelled at at work because
everybody knows about that uh knows
about what happened and uh also he you
know his car gets vandalized and [ __ ]
like that
so he's they're kind of uh all sitting
around drinking and eating weed brownies
one night and they're trying to figure
out like what can we do like what can we
do to get this jax douche off your back
uh so you can maybe start writing again
or get back into your career make
everybody forget about it so what he
decides to do he's like well uh
basically we're gonna fight fire with
fire what we're gonna do
is we're gonna come up with some stupid
uh internet challenge that will go viral
that's about puka um that will kind of
like take the heat off me a little bit
so that's kind of what they do so
essentially what they do is they write a
creepy pasta which they call eerie pasta
in this bowl i wasn't aware creepypasta
was a copyrighted term uh maybe they
just wanted to play it safe i'm not
really sure but they actually call it
eerie pasta but you know you know what i
mean so they decide that they're going
to uh you know do a creepypasta about
puka and summoning puka's creator who
his name was ellie now i forgot to
mention that there's actually a prologue
which stars will whedon by the way
there's a prologue to this movie which
kind of shows it's like i said i guess
it's like a little bit of a retcon
because i can't remember it's been like
more than a year since or you know it's
been like a year since i saw the first
movie so i can't remember
if they said in the first movie like who
the creator of puka was i thought that i
thought i remembered in that movie that
it was already like this big famous toy
and i don't know if they brought up who
created it but in this movie they posit
that the creator of puka was this woman
named ellie who had worked for this
company and they bought the design off
her and then they wanted to change it
and she flipped out because she has this
weird kind of connection with puka so
she uh flipped out when they wanted to
change it and she ends up getting into
argument with her husband about it
because she gets fired from her job and
like dragged out by security and uh so
she ends up stabbing uh will wheaton to
death it you know not actual will
wheaton but her husband
who's played by will wheaton in the
movie and then sets herself up and the
house on fire so this had happened like
a year prior to the events of this movie
so what they do the creepypasta they
come up with is um you have to do this
thing where you
eat ashes it's called the puka challenge
obviously you eat ashes to represent uh
you know the fire that she that ellie
set herself on fire
and also oh and she was wearing a pooka
mask when she did it and it melted to
her face because actually the guy that's
the sheriff benny that's a friend of
theirs uh shows them shows them the uh
the crime scene photos because he was
the one that had to go to the scene
right they're like why did you have that
like cued up on your phone like that so
there's like these little kind of funny
moments like that
so you have to eat ashes and then you
have to do the pooka song you know puka
si puka do you have to do that and uh
then you have to but with different
lyrics like saying so or essentially
what you're supposed to be doing it's
kind of like candy man or bloody mary or
something like that where you know
you're summoning
ellie's spirit in the form of puka and
he's gonna he she is gonna judge you uh
if you're nice or if you're naughty and
if you're naughty he's gonna like [ __ ]
you up
so they do this they post this challenge
anonymously obviously on like a
creepypasta type website and of course
it goes viral everybody starts doing it
uh and then as they quickly determine uh
and i think this is in the trailer which
is like you know we use the internet the
internet has literally created a monster
so apparently what happens is that
because this challenge becomes so
widespread
uh it starts to morph the way a lot of
these creepypastas do whether you're
talking about slenderman or you know
momo or whatever i think they even
mention momo in this actually
uh where people start doing their own
spins on it and as they like fan art and
stories and things like that so people
start adding to the puka legend oh now
puka has claws now he's like biggest
this one has lederhosen on you know this
one like you know this one's like it
looks like a big [ __ ] werewolf or a
wendigo or something like that so as it
starts to
evolve and morph they essentially
the internet the collective belief of it
essentially brings it to life in
different forms
so that's pretty much like what i mean
they explain later on like molly the new
age chick played by uh felicia day that
they've essentially created a tulpa
like an imaginary friend uh but because
so many people believed it they
literally like wheeled it into existence
so that's essentially what this is so
puka as it goes on puka starts looking
different uh in different iterations and
he can start he has like more powers now
like suddenly has claws suddenly uh he
can teleport suddenly he can do [ __ ]
that he couldn't do before just because
people keep adding on to the story so
obviously the five of them are freaking
out because you know it takes them a
long time to figure out what's going on
at first uh susan gets attacked by
somebody that just looks like somebody
in a pooka suit and they kind of think
that oh it's that douche bag that works
where they work that's been harassing
derek so they just think it's that uh
and matt who's played by jenna ray he
really does not believe any of this [ __ ]
is going on he just thinks like
somebody's doing pranks and all this
other kind of [ __ ] but as it goes on
like people start getting accused of
like murdering their whole families like
there's one news story about a guy
murdered his whole family in germany and
then when they put him in jail he's like
no puka did it and of course like nobody
believed it um so they're kind of going
the route of you know like the
slenderman stabbings like those two
little girls like in real life that you
know that stabbed their friend
thankfully not to death um because they
said slenderman told them to so it's so
it's kind of going in that direction and
it's also kind of the film's not like
really heavy-handed but it is kind of
like doing a satire of
sort of like online negativity
uh you know bullying stuff like that and
also goes into the power of storytelling
and how
somebody can come up with a fairly
innocuous story and have it morphed into
ways that they didn't expect and it kind
of gets out of their control as other
people get hold of it and in this case
ended up being really negative so
obviously puka is going around in
different forms you know killing people
attacking people and uh so they have to
find some way to stop it so they come up
with another creepypasta of how to kill
pooka and it's supposed to happen like
on this big international pooka day
presentation that they're doing and all
this other stuff now uh so i'm not gonna
spoil it too much because this movie is
not that old i think it just came out in
two 2020 or i think it was 2020 it came
out so last christmas um or last april
actually or april i can't remember maybe
it was april 2020. um so i don't want to
spoil it too much if you want to see it
like i said it's on hulu it's their into
the dark series if you liked the first
puka you'll probably like this one as
well but it's a very very different type
of movie it's kind of more the first one
was kind of more surreal uh you know
more psychological type of horror
whereas like one dude is like is he
going crazy or is puka really doing this
[ __ ] um you know what i mean so that had
that whole kind of thing going on
whereas this one is a lot more satirical
even though it does have a lot of horror
elements to it now one complaint that i
saw because it does seem like most
people seem to dig this one i i don't
know if i liked it as much as the first
one but it's kind of hard to compare
them because they're kind of different
you know they just have a different
thrust and like a whole different
vibe about them um but i did actually
like really enjoy this one a lot but one
criticism that i saw and this didn't
actually bother me
but uh they said well it ended sort of
on
a cliffhanger if you want to call it
that
um you know at the end it's kind of like
they
they do what they're supposed to do and
like defeat things but then it looks
like shit's about to get like way way
worse
and then it ends so i don't know if
they're actually setting up a third puka
movie or if they just didn't have the
budget to film this big epic thing that
they wanted to film because there is
like during the credits there is like an
animated sequence that kind of shows you
what happened next so they did do that
but like i said just it was probably
just budget constraints although it's
very very possible that they could be
setting up a third movie because you
know it would be kind of tailor-made for
that it's you know the last scene of the
movie all the stuff that happens you
know you could totally see
another one that goes like much bigger
scale um as i said that didn't bother me
that it ended like that because i was
just kind of like oh okay fine if they
make another one fine if they don't
that's fine too um you know it was kind
of cool that it ended like that but
honestly like i said i i actually had a
really good time with this one um i
really liked i enjoyed seeing all the
different
versions of puka like because that's
pretty much exactly what would happen if
you put up a creepypasta with a
character that really resonated with
people and then people would start doing
their own scarier versions of it and
that's essentially what happens here you
know and also the whole thing about you
know online toxicity and kind of these
you know douchebag youtubers that can
you know you say something to piss them
off and then they have so many fans that
they can just like ruin your whole
life or like could drive you offline or
whatever
and so i like that it kind of looked
into that but as i said it's not real
heavy-handed about it it's actually like
pretty funny and honestly other than
like all the puka designs and stuff like
that i really really liked seeing uh
jonah rae and felicia day in this they
were really funny and uh i just really
liked all the interactions between the
friends and it's weird because derek
who's the main character and susan who's
kind of like his on again well his love
interest because they broke up like back
in high school or whatever and then he's
trying to get back with her they were
actually kind of more they were kind of
boring characters you know what i mean
as in they were just kind of like
regular ass people whereas matt and uh
his wife molly were more kind of like
fun sort of characters and the [ __ ] the
sheriff benny he was also like super
super funny um you know with all his
stuff about his
his being a sheriff and like wanted to
be like super hot super hot gay guy and
all this other kind of stuff and i
thought that was like really funny like
how that interaction but yeah this was
like a lot of fun as i said it's not
really a christmas movie uh it's not
really a holiday movie and it does you
don't have to have seen the first puka
to understand this one because it
doesn't other than the puka character
being a big popular toy it doesn't
really have anything to do with the
first one uh so they both like pretty
standalone uh but yeah if you like kind
of like horror comedy type stuff uh if
you like kind of i don't want to say
like killer doll because it's not really
like that because the when the pooka is
attacked they're kind of
they're kind of life-sized you know what
i mean
um but yeah i really like seeing all the
different versions of puka that came out
and uh yeah it was just like a fun it's
very very fun very very entertaining yes
the ending is a little bit anticlimactic
but i understand they don't have a lot
of budget to work with with these and
honestly it's fine it didn't really
bother me that it ended where it ended
um you know if they make another one
with like
pookie arm and like i said pookie
because that's my cat with puka armies
or whatever i think that would look
pretty cool but if they don't then
that's fine too but yeah it's on hulu
part of their into the dark series uh
let me know if you've seen it and what
you thought about it and i will see you
guys on the next flickers of fear bye